مساء الخير السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته
احيانا سعيد
بلقائكم
هذا المساء
لكن بنلتقي في ظرف
عصيب وضع يعني اقل ما يوصف به في السودان
من وضع كارثي
قنا اليوم بعد انا في يوم امس
ارسلت نداء
لخصت فيه
ثلاث رسائل
رساله الاولى
كانت لقياده
الجيش وقياده الدعم السريع
وطالبتهم في انه يجب ان تقف هذه الحرب
ان هي حرب
المنتصر فيها خاسر
الرساله الثانيه
كانت
للشعب السوداني
ناشدتهم في الحفاظ على التماسك والوحده
ورساله الثالثه والاخيره
كانت للمجتمع الاقليمي والدولي
لمساعده
السودان والوقوف بجانبه في هذه المحنه
حقيقه
تابعتم امس واليوم
ما زالت
هذه الحرب
اللعينه
تقضي على الاخضر واليابس
ايضا
السبب الرئيسي
بعد نداء الامس
الذي جعلني التقي بكم هذا المساء
تتابعون الوضع
الانساني الكارثي في السودان
معاناه الانسان السوداني في ظل هذه الحرب
اصلا
المعاناه كانت موجوده
من اقتصاد
منهار متدني
نقص في كل الاشياء فالغذاء في الدواء
تفاقم هذا الوضع بشكل اكبر في هذه الحرب
هنالك انقطاع مستمر
التيار الكهربائي المياه الى اخره
لذلك
انا ودت التقيكم اليوم
لاكرر ما قلته بالامس
يجب ان تقف هذه الحرب
اليوم قبل غدا
لاتاحه الفرصه
للشعب السوداني بكل مكوناته
ليعود
لمسار الانتقال الذي بدا
من اكثر ما من ثلاثه سنوات
ايضا لن امر تكرار
يظل السلام هو الخيار الوحيد
المتاح للشعب السوداني
لتفادي الانزلاق
للحرب الاهليه
كلنا تابعنا
مالات الحرب الاهليه في مناطق كثيره من
اقليمنا في العالم العربي والافريقي
يجب ان نتفادى ذلك وما زالت الفرصه متاحه
لتفادى هذا الوضع الكارثه
لذلك نطالب
بوقف فوري
اطلاق النار
والوصول لتفاهمات تؤدي الى الوقف الدائم
في العادات
في اقل تقدير يجب ان يعني نعمل على قيام
هدنه تسمح بخلق ممرات امنه تسمح للمواطنين
بانهم يقضوا حاجات في الدواء
والعلاج والمستلزمات المعيشه من غذاء الى
اخره الى اخره
ايضا
انا اعتقد انه
ما في بديل
لغير اننا كسودانيين نقعد مع بعض في حوار
يؤدي
[موسيقى]
لحل مرضي لكل فئات الشعب السوداني
انا بركز على كلمه حوار
تفاوض مفضي للاتفاق
في تاريخنا القريب في خلال
الكمون سنه الماضيه عظم الاشياء
تحققت في هذه الفتره عندما اجمع الشعب
السوداني بكل اقواه الحيه
هذا الاجماع الفريد حقك استقلال السودان
في 56
اسقط الديكتاتوريه الاولى في 64
في 85 وايضا في هذه المره في 2019
لذلك لا يوجد بديل للحوار الا الحوار انا
ايضا
من هذا المنبر
اناشد
وادعو
للرفض اي تدخل اجنبي في الشان السوداني
ولذلك ندعو المجتمع الدولي
يمارس الدور ايجابي لدعم
[موسيقى]
عوده الحوار السياسي
وايضا اكرر الدعوه
لقياده
الجيش
وقياده الدعم السريع
للجلوس فورا في مفاوضات
تؤدي لمعالجه وحلحله الخلافات التي ادت
لهذا الوضع
ايضا
قبل ان اختم هذه المداخله
ادعو الدول
العربيه
والافريقيه والشقيقه
لمسانده الشعب السوداني
الذي يمر بظروف انسانيه صعبه جدا
تطلب تضافر جهود كل المجتمع الدولي في هذه
المحنه
وفي هذا الاطار
سوف ابذل كل الجهد
للمساعده في هذه العمليه
سوف اقوم باجراء اتصالات
بكل العواصم
لتشجيعهم على التحرك على وجه السرعه
لتقديم كل المساعدات الانسانيه الممكنه
للشعب السوداني ومساعدته في هذه المهنه
اختم بعبارات
زعيم من الافريقي نيلسون مانديلا
عندما قال
سهل جدا
انك
تهدم وتكسر
الابطال هم من يبنون ويصنعون السلام
شكرا جزيلا